n
font aussi leur apparition
dans la grille.
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est vous, le journaliste?
- Et c'est reparti pour une
nouvelle saison télévisuelle.
Une saison presque normale,
malgré la pandémie qui
complexifie les tournages.
FRANCE BEAUDOIN,
animatrice et productrice
- La première des choses, c'est
que tout le monde a tourné;
tout le monde a pu réaliser
ce qu'il avait à réaliser.
Il y a eu des exploits,
j'ose dire "exploits"
parce que tout le monde
a trouvé les solutions.
- France Beaudoin sera
de retour à la barre
de "En direct de l'univers".
Au chapitre des nouveautés,
"Nuit Blanche", une saga
familiale mettant en vedette
France Castel et
Rose-Marie Perreault.
- On va leur montrer
que c'est pas juste en ville
que le monde se révolte.
Le Québec explose de partout.
- Les téléspectateurs pourront
aussi découvrir "Après",
une série mettant en vedette
Karine Vanasse et qui raconte
une histoire de courage et
de résilience dans une petite
communauté des Laurentides.
- C'est vous autres qui avez tué
mon Jérôme en faisant rien.
- Parmi les retours attendus,
Roy Dupuis reprend son rôle
de Christophe L'Allier, mais une
nouvelle responsable pédagogique
fera son entrée à l'école,
Marie Labrecque, pour le
meilleur ou pour le pire.
Des beaux-parents s'ajoutent
à la distribution de
"Discussion avec mes parents"...
alors que la mort rôdera,
dès les premiers épisodes
de "District 31".
VINCENT-GUILLAUME OTIS,
comédien, "District 31"
- Tout ce que je peux dire,
en fait, c'est que j'espère
que les gens vont être
confortablement assis dans
leur chaise parce que ça va...
dans leur fauteuil, parce que
ça va déménager cette année.
Ça part sur les
chapeaux de roue.
- Surprise!
- Radio-Canada poursuit
son virage jeunesse
avec des émissions comme
"Alix et les merveilleux",
"L'agent Jean" ou
"L'effet secondaire",
en plus de 23 nouveautés
qui seront ajoutées à la grille,
dont "Défense d'entrer",
la série inspirée des
livres de Caroline Héroux.
- Allez-vous vous présenter
contre Valérie Plante
aux prochaines élections
municipales?
- Guy A. Lepage est de retour
à la barre de "Tout le monde
en parle"; Anais Favron et
Alexandre Barrette alterneront
avec des co-animateurs d'un soir
dans le rôle des fous du roi.
"Infoman" ne manquera pas
de sujets avec les campagnes
électorales en cours et
les suites de la pandémie.
L'an dernier, Radio-Canada
a connu une année record.
DANY MELOUL, dg, de la
télévision, Radio-Canada
- Ce qui est arrivé avec la
pandémie, c'est que les gens
sont retournés vers des valeurs
sûres et ont trouvé leur compte.
Et on dirait qu'ils ont
redécouvert le bien-être
d'être chez soi et d'écouter
de belles émissions.
- Une rentrée télé variée,
qui promet d'être captivante.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M